I have like an hour okay thank you I
just want to make some some informal
remarks about teaching online at Yale
this is going to be brief I noticed a
Q&A period but if anybody's interested
in doing it and wants an honest
assessment of what it's like in detail I
can't get into here I'm just phone me or
shoot me an email and I'm happy to
follow up with anybody I've taught at
the to sort of extreme scales the very
small and very large regarding online
courses the small one is a summer course
which I've been involved in teaching for
the last two summers and i'm planning to
teach at next summer and this came from
I taught the Devane lectures a few years
ago on moralities of everyday life and I
decided to you and these were filmed and
I decided use it as the basis for a
summer course so the course I would
interact with students over the summer
there would be a small group of student
weaned 14 and 18 um they would watch the
class to videotape class and then they
would interact with me and then it even
attract me once a week and it would also
interact with teaching fellow um and we
would do so over laptop so there was a
you know a software do you see all the
students faces and you you interact in
ACU and so on and I don't have that much
to say about it because in many regards
it was perfectly indistinguishable from
teaching any other course it had certain
disadvantages I think I still prefer
meeting people in the flesh I still
prefer to actual sort of standard
looking at them and seeing them there's
a reason why world here instead of sort
of on the screen but but there are also
certain advantages I found a class moved
a lot quicker and I was much able better
able to monitor the the students
performance and relative contribution
and so on as they you know and I would
point to them and name them and I felt
that there was much more contribution we
sped things up a little bit another
advantage is the simple convenience of
it the first time I taught this course
was in China and I just did as 12 hour
time difference but if we just we just
made our way through it um then there's
everyday convenience of not having to go
to an actual
room and find your way there and you
don't even have to wear pants actually
um which is important um so so so on a
large scale I'm also involved in
teaching a MOOC this is my moralities
course but this time I'm doing it again
I'm keeping it at the Yale studios and
right now I have about 46,000 students
enrolled in the course somebody emailed
me today to tell me that he's dropping
it so I unless that's gonna appreciate
it um it's hard for me to get into too
much details about a pros and cons
because because it hasn't started yet
i'll know a lot more in a month I'll
tell you one con which I didn't expect
which is that the way I'm doing this
course is I'm going to the studios and
presenting my lectures while camera men
film me and I had never imagined how
difficult it is to teach to nobody it is
it is it is now my new i think is a very
good metaphor for hell to stand and try
to be funny and engaging to total
silence and then afterwards that you
know the cameraman came over and said i
thought something you said it might have
been amusing so we're taping it what
we're going to do now we're done taping
i want to do now it's going to add
quizzes for the courses are going to add
exams when it launches in january along
with an extremely competent Teaching
Fellow I'm going to hold office hours
meaning that people email me questions
and then what we'll do a Q&A to teach me
felt well it will give me the questions
I'll answer them I'm going to invite
guests over and again the students will
provide me with questions to ask the
guests I guess it's going to be major
figures in my in my field some who have
already agreed to participate and we're
going to construct some sort of social
media for for the students to interact
with one another um I've heard a critic
described MOOCs as books on tape I like
books on tape I you know is that way
yeah it's a book on tape I'm quite
comfortable creating a book on tape
that's that's a fine contribution to
book on tape with some quizzes and exams
and social media some sort of contact
additionally um I think it falls I I
don't think a MOOC is going to replace a
seminar
I have much rather i think i'd much
rather myself a restaurant of my son
who's going to college next year take
seminars den MOOCs another hand what
this MOOC used to be was a large lecture
course and it looks probably better than
that large lecture courses you know if
we didn't already have them and somebody
proposed them people would say what a
ridiculous idea and i'm saying that as
somebody who's teaching one next
semester so i'm not giving anybody a
hard time i I'm finding this exciting
much more difficult than I would have
imagined and I'm looking forward to
seeing how it works out thank you